estoy justamente fuera de un centro de
votación uno de los más importantes de
una zona muy populosa de la capital
efectivamente
lo importante de esta votación es que se
van a elegir diputados al congreso algo
que el presidente bucl es reiteradamente
ha dicho que hace un tropiezo o una
piedra en el zapato para sus decisiones
gubernamentales entonces se espera que
tras la elección como distintos sondeos
de opinión lo han revelado pues el
presidente logre obtener una bancada
importante que logre respaldar las
decisiones gubernamentales claro que sí
pero también brain y la oposición ha
advertido que si buque le acumula más
poder se vería en riesgo la
independencia de las instituciones que
argumentos hay tanto de un lado como del
otro
efectivamente lo que está en juego ahora
es que si el presidente bucl le llegara
a tener mayoría como lo prevén todos los
sondeos de opinión y esperemos al final
de la jornada electoral si los
resultados así lo presentan ese
presidente llegará a tener una mayoría
en el congreso pues podría elegir
magistrados de la corte suprema de
justicia fiscal general de la república
entre otras entidades importantes que de
las que también se ha que ha quejado el
presidente bucl e que son obstáculos en
su gestión gubernamental entonces
prácticamente estaríamos hablando de que
lograría el presidente bucl tener el
control del ejecutivo
el legislativo y el poder judicial algo
que preocupa como tú bien lo ha dicho
a otras
esferas internacionales porque
acumularía demasiado poder